♪ ♪ ♪
- Des kilomètres et des
kilomètres de côtes.
Pour les municipalités
gaspésiennes nichées
un peu leur colonne vertébrale.
Car la proximité aveerererer a
longtemps rimé avec prospérité.
Mais le vent pourrait tourner.
- Puis ici, c'est le trop-plein.
- Nous sommes à Sainte-Anne-
Simon Deschênes, et son équipe,,
ce n'est rien de nouveau.
Mais avec le dérèglement
est devenue colossale.
SIMON DESCHÊNES,
maire de Sainte-Anne-des-Monts
- On nage à contre-coe.e.e.e.e.s
une séance du conseil, encore
hier soir, qu'il y ait
un citoyen : "Eille, l'érosion
côtièreSiSiSiSiSiSiSiSiSiSiSiSis
à un endroit, il faut que
je le fasse pour tout le monde.
Je ne suis pas capable d'ouvrir
- C'est que l'eau du fleuve
Saint-Laurent se réchauffe,eeeee
d'eau et disparaîtrelelelele co,
laissant les côtes toutes nues
devant des tempêtescececececece.
Les scientifiques estiment qu'à
certains endroits, le littoral
pourrait perdre plusieurs mètres
d'ici la fin du siimimimimimimi.
- Salut, Kevin. Ça va bien?
- Oui, ça va bien, toi?
En forme?
- Ce matin, le maire a rendez-
le propriétaire du motel-
restaurant Manoir r.r.r.r.
- Les gens vont être inondés
au printemps prochain...
qu'il n'a pas pu autoriser
ses plans ndndndndissement.
KEVIN PELLETIER, propriétaire,
motel-restaurant Manoir sur Mer
même quelques mois d'avance
popépépépériode de la Saint-Jean
jusqu'à la fête du Travail.
Puis là, on s'est dit : bien,ent
de pouvoir agrandir.enenenentre.
Puis, finalement, bien, ça...
on n'a pas eu les autorisatiitit
de le faire.
t t t t que la Ville doit
appliquer la nouvelle
réglementation provincialelalal,
qui est très contraignante.
L'entrepreneur est en plus
laissé à lui-même pour protéger
l'intégrité de son terrain,
de plus en plus par la mer.
Alors, toute cette portion,
le gravier tout le tour?
- Oui, exactement. C'était perdu
au complet, puis les marches
cinq pieds plus bas. Il fallait
monter dans nos marches pour
redescendre de l'autre côté.
Donc, c'est après ça que
le muret de béton est arrivé.
hiver d'énormes blocs de béton.
Un ouvrage de près de 100 000 $
qu'il a dû payer seul.
ça pouvoir rêver, j'aimerais
ça pouvoir vrarararand.
Cette année, c'est sûr que j'ai
eu un petit découragement
- L'élu s'est donné comme
mission d'acnenenener citoyens
et entrepreneurs qui vivent
des problèmes liés à l'érosion.
que sa ville se vide.
Surtou s s s selon l'indice
de vitalité des MRC,
la MRC de la Haute-Gaspésie,
se classe bonne dernière
leleleles 104.- - - - Salut, Si!
- Ah, salut, Serge!
- Ça va bien?
à la rencontre d'un propriétaire
d'un bloc appartements de sept
logements. Serge Chrétien a
découvert que son immeu u u u u.
Il est donc incapable
de le vendre.
SERGE CHRÉTIEN, résident,
Sainte-Anne-isisisisisisisisisi,
c'est une zone inondable,
donc ça va pratiquement
jusqu'à la première avenue,
doncde faire des changements
à partir de ce moment-là.
- Pour être conforme,
cinq des sept logements.n n n nt
partait au vent.
Une situation absurde,ntntntntns
que la ville vit une pénurie
de logements.
L'élu vient lui annoncer
qu'après avoir fait d, , , , , l
a finalement trouvé une façon
de régulariser son dossier.
- Les gens de l'urbanisme,
les greffi d d d d d d d d d d e
pour trouver une solution.
- Mais s'il peut compter sur
une oreille attentive au conseil
muni
les niveaux de gouvernement
supérieurs, il a l'impression
de parler dans le vide.
- Je pense que les instances
ont baissé les bras.
Leèèèème est trop grand.
On dirait qu'ils ne veulent pas
s'attaquer à ça.isisisisisisisié
et ça va être trop d'argent.
- Des situations complexes
pour la municipalité de 6500
rési s s s selon le maire.
D'autant plus que la Ville
de ses 17 kilomètres de route
municipale sur la c
Le maire croit que
les gouvernement
déconnectés de la réalité.
- Donc moi, j'ai des
infrastructures égouts, aqueducs
sur le bord de la mer.
Si opapapapas cette vision
à long terme pour lutter contre
les changements climatiques,quqa
s'occuper de mes infrastructurer
en gondole? On va me laisser
tenter de réparer ça aux frastst
impensable d'y parvenir seul.
- Le ministère des Transports
du Québec spspspsponsable
de protéger ses routes.
Il prépare une é4,4,4,4,4,4,4,4e
d'élaborer un plan d'action.
Trop peu, trop tard, selon
le maire, qui déplore en plus
d'être IcIcIcIcIcIcIcIcIcIcIcIct
de proximité". Alors, on nous
laisse la responsabilité,
puis on nage dans ça,
ma
la législation entre les mains.
Donc, on fait quoi pour
y parvenir? Ça devient
excessivement difficile.
de s'éloigner de la mer,eseseser
à leur identité culturelle,